[Music]
some of the best food i had in india
was street food and every little food
stall
was cooking up something spicy something
delicious
a little teaspoon of oil gonna toast off
a teaspoon of cumin mustard seeds
a touch of salt and pepper
lightly fry them off it's really
important to cook off the spices
it intensifies the flavor but really
draws out that nice
spicy deep rich flavor so
onion three fingers one in front two
behind
nice and fine
onions in now
we're going to caramelize those onions
mustard seeds have started to infuse
cumin has that nice kick
now with a little touch of butter in
there get it nice and sort of rich
gas up nice and high and really
caramelised onions now
once the onions have turned a rich
golden color that's what i'm looking for
that is beautiful add baby spinach
keep that pan nice and hot if you don't
cook it out
the actual breakfast ends up watering
when the spinach is cooked set aside and
it's onto the spicy eggs
now the breakfast really starts to come
alight four nice eggs
now give those eggs a little whisk a
little touch
of butter into the pan a little teaspoon
of oil so the butter doesn't burn when
the butter and oil are hot
add a teaspoon of garam masala and
turmeric
cook that out now take your eggs
into the pan
almost gonna make like a really nice
spicy scrambled egg
turn the gas down
now as the scrambled egg comes together
just finish that with a little bit of
butter i quite like the sort of
creaminess
makes it so much more delicious
and then from there you get my spinach
chop up and then fold in
the spinach to your scrambled egg
something quite exciting about eating
spice for breakfast
but it's served in these wonderful
little thin naan breads
this will work with any flatbread or
wrap you fancy and then lightly toast
your naan take the eggs off the heat
whilst you get on with the last
job add quick mint and spice yogurt
dressing
couple of tablespoons of fresh yogurt
in there's always something to take out
the heat
then add chopped mint salt and turmeric
mix that in
now take a scrambled egg
and half fill banana it smells
incredible
get your yogurt
down on top and lift that over
and for me that's what really stands out
with street food
in india how delicious they can make
street food with a little bit of spice
amazing
[Music]
once you try this spicy wrap i promise
you scrambled eggs will never taste the
same
the secret to a really good madeline is
it's light
fluffy delicious and it's perfect
with the coffee in the morning so melt
the butter gently
next crack three eggs
that was one of the most exciting things
about living in paris there was always
something there in that little pastry
shop that used to live above
gotta incorporate the sugar
and then give that a really good whisk
because it's important to incorporate
some air now the secret to whisking
is a big beautiful balloon whisk the
bigger the balloon whisk
the more aeration you'll get in the
mixture so
best thing to do is just go from left to
right
and then change hands every 15 or 20
seconds
so your hands never get tired and tilt
the ball to your advantage as well
now you can see the mixture starting to
air it's almost double in size
the more you whisk this the lighter it
becomes
so it starts to almost look like a light
whipped cream
gone is that dark rich egg yolk color
beautiful once the eggs and sugar become
pale creamy and thick
sift in the self-raising flour sieve in
the flour
now i'm giving my madeline's a twist by
adding poppy seeds for a crunch
and lemon for flavor the zest of lemon
in there
generous on the lemon lime is wonderful
orange zest again beautiful i've even
made
pink grapefruit madeline's with poppy
seeds delicious
but lemon for me is the best
pour the melted butter down the side of
the bowl
so it cools down even more and then
combine start mixing that in
it's really important at this stage that
we don't beat
the mixture i want to keep that nice
aerated texture
across the madeleine mix so i'm going to
use a spatula now
and just gently mix my butter in
now give that a good mix and they say
that the longer you make them mix up in
advance
the higher they raise in the oven look
at that
it looks beautiful leave that to sit
there
[Music]
and we'll butter and line our moulds
you can make these in little miniature
yorkshire pudding
molds i've even seen madeline's been
cooked in espresso cups so
if you haven't got the traditional
madeline tray
yorkshire pudding trays
are just as good lightly butter
the inside of the tray take a tablespoon
of flour
and the secret now is to lie in the
mould with a flour that stops
any chance of the madeline sticking
tap the sieve into all the little
grooves
and this will ensure that they'll come
out instantly
then all you do then is just stand up
the tray and tap it two or three times
and you'll see the flower
roll out
so there you go the baking sheet
lined beautifully no excess butter and
no excess flour
the beauty of this recipe is that you
can make it the night before and then
simply bake it in the morning
when you're ready to go put the mixture
into a jug to make it really easy to
pour into the tin
give it a little stir so you've got that
nice even distribution of those poppy
seeds
and just gently
lovely film up to the top
oh beautiful so much easier pouring this
from a jug because you get
the exact amount in in the oven 180
degrees
do not open that door before 10 minutes
and wait for that wonderful surprise
[Music]
they smell amazing now
a little tap on the side of the tray and
this would just all pop
out beautifully
that smell is unique
that nice soft crisp
outside with this lovely fragrant fluffy
center
and the secret of a great madeline as
the french would swear by it
is this lovely little mound on top they
call it the nipple
but that is the confirmation
that is perfect my poppy and lemon
madeleines
are a sophisticated continental start to
the day and take me straight back to
paris
the secret of a good chip butty
is in the potato now these are
desiree potatoes one of my first ever
jobs
was working in a chip shop i used to put
sacks and sacks of potatoes into the
rumbler which will send the potato
peeler
all day long today i'm gonna do
something a bit healthier
for my oven chips with a twist simply
peel
slice and blanch for three to four
minutes
drain season and cover well
with propeca spread evenly over an oiled
baking tray
and place into a preheated oven for 20
minutes
simple as that next up easy fish fingers
this is pollock a really nice firm
delicious
fish got the fish in finger size batons
of fish
put them onto your plate and just
lightly salt them
you can do that literally 20 minutes 30
minutes before
you start cooking the fish it firms the
fish up beautifully
and it allows it to become a little bit
more durable especially in the pan
now for the coating start by thoroughly
coating the fish
in seasoned flour and then just roll it
to get rid of those little sharp corners
because then
it stops those corners almost burning in
the pan
in to your egg wash and really coat them
wonderful and then this is dill
goes brilliantly well with a fish and
run the dill
through my breadcrumbs that makes it
more aromatic
lay them onto your breadcrumbs
nothing wrong with the chip butty
nothing wrong with fish fingers
just give it a lovely modern twist
beautiful
once the fish fingers are thoroughly
coated they're ready to pan fry
and they'll need around three minutes on
each side
i want the fish fingers to be nice and
crispy get a really nice color on them
first
and then we'll flip them over and finish
them with butter
bring the heat up into the pan nice
little knob of butter
that'll work wonders with the
breadcrumbs and the dill
nice and carefully take them out
they look and smell incredible stay nice
and crispy
now to assemble my chip butty starting
with buttered thick crusty bread
a slice of bread mop up
that amazing flavor
on slice in half
never slice in an angle
my mouth is salivating beautiful
on with the ship butty there's one thing
missing
and it signifies that i've never
forgotten the joy i've come for food
but my god that makes me feel like a
nine year old
excuse me for a moment when you want to
stuff my face
[Applause]
[Music]
homemade fish fingers and my ultimate
chip buddy
so simple to make but trust me it tastes
amazing